les réactions sont nombreuses à
l'annoncé de cette nomination c'est une
décision politique disent les uns pas du
tout bernard attali a fait la preuve de
ses compétences c'est l'homme de la
situation répondent les autres alors en
désespoir d'arguments les indices aux
autres en tout cas si c'est politique
vous l'avez fait avant nous bref voici
les réactions de pierre méhaignerie et
alain juppé qui tous les deux tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé l'an buissière
j'estime que l'interruption brutale d'un
président eux qui avaient commencé à
travailler en profondeur
c'est un très mauvais service à rendre
au pays et à la bonne gestion des
entreprises publiques et je suis tenté
de poser la question où on est on du
discours sur l'impartialité de l'état et
la non ingérence du pouvoir politique
dans les grandes entreprises publiques
je crois que c'est très clair il
s'agissait de placer le frère d'un des
conseillers du président de la
république c'est un exemple
caractéristique de népotisme est de
retour à l'esprit de valence
la méthode n'est pas tout à fait la même
qu'en 1981 elle est moins brutal et
moins immédiate mais jour après jour
nous voyons se succéder des décisions de
ce type qui manifeste la volonté du
pouvoir socialiste de remettre la main
sur tous les postes de responsabilité je
crois que maintenant les choses sont
claires